[موسيقى]
اذا المجموعه الاولى تبوح بكل اسرارها في
الجوله الاولى او تبوح باسرار الجوله
الاولى فعليا الكامله هولندا الان تتقاسم
الصداره مع منتخب الاكوادور بالمقابل
السنغال وقطر بنفس الرصيد من النقاط صفر
من النقاط وبنفس الرصيد من الاهداف ايضا
المسجله في مرماهما بهدفين لكل فريق منهما
اليوم المنتخب الهولندي هل كان مقنعا لم
يكن مقنع بكل امانه هل للمنتخب الهولندي
كان قادرا على تقديم شيء يطمئن هذا
الجمهور الذي حضر الى الملعب او الجمهور
الموجود في هولندا ابدا اخطاء كانت بكل
بساطه انه ااه
خال مصر على الخمسه ثلاثه اثنين مصر على
هذا الاسلوب على وجود الاخت لسبب غير
معروف يمكن سبب الخبره وانا بقدر على هذا
الكلام لذلك هو افضل دلخت على تمبرز مثلا
وعلى غيره من اللاعبين الدفاع ولكن ديفرين
موجود وبخبره اكبر ديلخ في الشوط المباراه
الاول كان ممكن نتكلم في منتخب هولندا
هدفين على الاقل وبالتالي يعني كان ممكن
تكون كارثه بالنسبه لهولندا لو تلقت هدف
مبكر في هذه المباراه بالمقابل الموضوع
ديل بلان ايضا علامه استفهام اخرى بالنسبه
للمنتخب الهولندي دفاعيا ديلبلين مقبول
ولكن امام سرعات اسماعيل يسار على الجهه
اليمنى كان الموضوع صعب جدا بالنسبه اليوم
حتى وجود يعني لاعبين بقيمه همم ينسن
وبقيمه بارجواين بالهجوم اعتقد انه علامات
استفهامك كبيره على اداء المنتخب الهولندي
واختيارات خال هجوميا المنتخب الهولندي
كان غير قادر يشكل اي خطوره تقريبا على
مرمى السنغال الا في مناسبهتين طيله
المباراه قبل ما يتسجل الهدف الاول الهدف
الاول يعني هو نسخه حرفيا بالكربون عن هدف
بيلينجهام على ايران رفعه من الجهه اليسرى
ولكن هذه المره بالقدم اليمنى عن طريق
ديون بدلا من القدم اليسرى ومع انجلترا
يتصدى لها لاعب قادم من الخلف لاعب بنفس
تقريبا ستايل ونفس الشكل حتى
يسجل الكره بالراس والهدف الاول للمنتخب
الهولندي سهل الامور سهل المباراه بعد ذلك
على منتخب هولندا وصارت الامور سهله وسجل
كلاسن الهدف الثاني لتنتهي المباراه
بهدفين مقابل لا شيء فوز غير مقنعه
لهولندا بكل المقاييس السنغال كانت تستحق
على الاقل التعادل في هذه المباراه اداء
رائع من السنغال اذا استمرت عليه قد تصل
الى الدور المقبل ولكن هولندا الان تتصدر
وهذا ما جرى في
المجموعه الاولى حتى الان الحديث الان عن
مباراه انجلترا وايران والتي انتهت
بسداسيه نظيفه للمنتخب الانجليزي اداء
مقنع بدايه مقنعه بالنسبه للمنتخب
الانجليزي قدم مستوى رائع جدا مسجل اول
اهدافه في كاس العالم على الاطلاق مع
منتخب انجلترا جيل وعد بالنسبه للكوره
الانجليزيه وجود ساكا ايضا بهدفين ساكن
الذي يسجل اوراق اعتمادها ايضا في كاس
العالم ويرد على منهجوه بنهائي كاس امم
اوروبا وقت تعرض له العنصريه كذلك الحال
بالنسبه لماركوس راشفورد ايضا رد على من
هاجمه في نهائي اليورو انجلترا بدايه
مبشره جدا بالمقابل منتخب ايران اعتقد انه
تاثر بالامور السياسيه شوي تاثر بما يحدث
في ايران حاليا همم لفتت اللاعبين بعدم
غناء النشيد الوطني كانت واضحه انه هي
رساله رساله للحكومه الايرانيه رساله لما
يحدث في ايران رساله دعم كانت موجوده من
جانب الجماهير ومن جانب اللاعبين للمحتجين
في ايران لذلك اعتقد انه العامل السياسي
والعامل النفسي اثر على اداء المنتخب
الايراني الذي يمكن ان يقدم اداء افضل من
ذلك بكثير وانا واثق انه منتخب ايران
بقادر مباريات سيقدم اداء افضل من ذلك
انجلترا قدمت اوراق اعتمادها في هذه
البطوله اعتقد انه الجميع اليوم سيرشح
انجلترا المنافسه على لقب هولندا
حتى نرى المنتخبات الكبيره التي ستلعب في
الايام المقبله في كاس العالم هذا الكلام
في وقتها لحتى نقدر نعرف هل فعلا هولندا
ستنافس هل فعلا انجلترا ستنافس ولكن حتى
الان انجلترا ممتازه جدا